rencontre au sommet à bagdad visite
ultra secrète du nouveau ministre les
affaires étrangères rob nicholson a tenu
à voir l'irak voir son combat contre le
groupe armé état islamique voir le fruit
des efforts canadiens sur le terrain
les frappes aériennes pour te fruits
affirme le ministre ont réussi à freiner
le groupe armé état islamique brownie
consignes évoque aussi et quelques 100
millions de dollars investis dans la
région pour venir en aide au
gouvernement irakien offrir un répit
face à la crise humanitaire qui touche
les milliers de victimes il prédit même
que le canada sera présent en irak à
long terme tout comme ce fut le cas en
afghanistan
la décision de prolonger la mission
militaire serait-elle donc déjà prises
le ministre affirme que non le chanterai
mais les forces canadiennes elles sont
prêtes même pour une mission plus longue
et plus complexe aussi voir en syrie
l'entraîneur requises pour exécuter les
missions en irak et or aucun
entraînement requise de surplus si vous
voulez afin d'exécuter des missions en
syrie si le gouvernement décide d'aller
dans cette direction
sur le terrain alors que les forces
irakiennes maine près de tikrit leur
plus vaste opération militaire elle
procède avec l'aide de l'iran sans les
forces de la coalition
le porte-parole des forces canadiennes
évite biais de s'aventurer sur le
terrain de possibles tensions entre la
coalition et le gouvernement irakien
tous nos engagements quand l on
approbation même du gouvernement irakien
et c'est ainsi que les cf 18 canadiens
n'ont effectué qu'une seule frappe
aérienne depuis la mi février en irak
est rien depuis nos jours
manuel c'est donc une accalmie pour le
canada mais ce n'est peut-être que
temporaire à quoi ce qu'il faut
s'attendre oui parce qu'il faut le dire
il ya plusieurs facteurs qui sont jeu
parmi les qualités la météo des
conditions difficiles sur le terrain
aussi semble-t-il fait que le groupe
armé est un islam extrême moins actif
sur le terrain en ce moment la question
que se posent les stratèges militaires
c'est que donc ce qu'une part de cette
accalmie ne relèverait pas d'une pause
volontaire de la part des militants qui
préparaient peut-être une vaste
offensive printanière comment on le
voyait à l'époque en afghanistan les
prochaines semaines vont nous dire quand
aussi il faut le souligner que les
forces armées irakiennes avec l'appui de
la coalition prépare quant à elle une
vaste offensive peut être en avril
l'armée dans l'espoir de reconquérir la
ville de mossoul ou alors parlons la
prolongation de la mission le
gouvernement a vont dire que l'addition
n'est pas tout à fait prise là il va
falloir qu'ils se décident assez
rapidement oui parce que l'échéance
arrive et 1 le 7 avril écouter les
signaux qu'envoie le gouvernement ses
ministres seniors comme ce n'est qu'au
dessus nous l'avons entendu aujourd'hui
monsieur kenny lune vous menez à
défendre dans les dernières semaines ne
sont pas les signaux d'un gouvernement
qui s'apprête à retirer ses billes au
contraire mais quelle forme prendra donc
la suite de l'engagement canadien en
irak le gouvernement soutient que la
décision reviendra très prochainement
échéance les gt tout ça bien sûr devra
être soumis à nouveau un vote aux
communes merci beaucoup et manuel pour
ses explications merci la meilleure voie